[Musique]
dans ce restaurant de cuisine du marché
la viande de lapin est souvent à
l'honneur
combien de temps ça mijoter ce beau plat
1 heure 45
merci merci Isabelle le copropriétaire
Pascal paradis affectionne ce produit de
niche qu'est-ce que tu lui trouves au
lapin c'est comment on pourrait décrire
cette viande là
recettes conventionnelles le poulet
c'est super intéressant de travailler
toutes les parties du lapin dans les
recettes et puis là on en est venu à ce
plat et vraiment super intéressant
ici le lapin est braisé aux xérès et ça
rappelle le coq au vin jaune du Jura
donc une région que j'adore pour les
vins et pour la nourriture donc on a
remplacé le coq par le lapin ensuite le
vin jaune qui est très cher par du bon
visérès qui a le côté oxydatif avec une
sauce crémée et on a décidé de le faire
avec des pleurotes érigées le râble on
l'a roulé sur une saucisse Toulouse de
chez Gaspard
le râble et la partie charnue du dos du
lapin une partie très prisée des
gourmets
[Musique]
qui était sur le en dessous une pièce de
viande qui est quand même délicate à
travailler est-ce que tu recommences
qu'on fait ça à la maison si on n'est
pas très habitué ça se fait quand même
assez bien moi je garde tout le temps la
partie des toutes les autres me font la
carcasse pour faire mon bouillon de
lapin par la presse pour mettre avec la
recette comme ça qu'est-ce que tu me
suggères de goûter en premier
parce que plus de travail ça mérite de
goûter
[Musique]
plus que je pensais
si tu veux défaire un peu la cuisse tu
vas voir qu'elle se défait super super
bien aussi là comme ça
puis là hop ça fait des beaux morceaux
de viande super tendres souvent on va
servir au choix du client soit la cuisse
soit le rap
au Canada la consommation de lapin est
non seulement minime mais en chute
depuis la dernière décennie aujourd'hui
au Québec moins de 20 fermes font de
l'élevage de lapin leur activité
principale
le lapin au menu ici on va démocratiser
un peu cette viande là qu'on mange pas
j'aimerais bien ça parce que c'est
vraiment une viande de qualité et où
est-ce que tu t'approches ça s'appelle
la ferme la rabouillère c'est une de mes
amis avec qui qui me permet d'avoir
cette viande là pour le restaurant
[Musique]
ferme la rabouillère de Jérémy pilon et
consacré à l'agro tourisme chef de
formation il offre une table champêtre
de l'hébergement ainsi qu'une boutique
remplie de produits de sa ferme les
visiteurs yveront deux types d'élevage
en récréatif et un pour la consommation
dont le lapin
on produit plus ou moins 500 600 700
lapins par année toute la file mieux en
marché est faite ici à la ferme avec
quelques connaissances admis
restaurateurs donc Pascal je constate
que le lapin sort bien chez vous lapin
de plus en plus populaire c'est vraiment
cool
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire exactement la
rabouillarde d'où ça vient la
rabouillasse c'est un terme de vieux
français qui signifie terrier de lapin
donc c'est ici
[Musique]
qu'on fait les accouples chez les pilons
de parents fils on a réduit la
production de lapin au gré de la
consommation de 500 femelles
reproductrices à une certaine époque
Jérémy compte maintenant 25 lapines et 5
mâles d'élevage il y a pas beaucoup
d'éleveurs qui qui ont fait ce choix là
ici au Québec ouais effectivement mais
c'est une viande pour moi qui gagne à
être connu mais qui est peut-être pas
grand public moi j'ai beaucoup de
clients qui viennent ici chercher leur
lapins puis ils vont toujours adorer le
lapin
ça reste un défi c'est sûr qu'il y a
toujours la question de à c'est un beau
petit animal c'est toujours particulier
qui dit lapin dit lapin à la moutarde
dans une classique
c'est une recette qui est bien simple tu
as vu il y a pas beaucoup d'ingrédients
puis c'est savoureux donc la sauce à la
moutarde et c'est une viande qui est
quand même pas c'est très goutteuse donc
j'imagine qu'elle prend assez facilement
les aromates quand il ajoute tout à fait
nous on aime ça aussi avec lardons et
pois vert je suis conscient que humain
doit manger moins de viande pour aider
la planète mais si j'ai un mot à dire
c'est danger moi maintenant manger de
meilleures qualités
[Musique]